let's hear from a few more people in the
audience we're doing it via discord
davidpakman.com
discord is the place to find
the mechanism for phone calls
let's go
to
oh let's try maria from maria from
columbus says that she's ready maria
you're on the air
hey can you hear me i can hear you now
maria what was happening before
i have no idea i have a discord open on
my laptop and now i'm on my phone so got
it don't know what that's about sorry
well i'm glad you were able to make it
on
yeah me too
uh i'm really sorry about your twitch
band it's a pretty [ __ ] in my
opinion yes please don't swear remember
this goes on the radio so every time you
swear we've got to bleep that pat please
make a note we're going to bleep maria
yes the twitch ban is a disappointment
for sure
yeah
um
so
i i appreciate you covering the trial
though it's
it's hard to talk with anyone else about
it everyone else seems very annoyed
about the whole thing um i am as well
i'm very frustrated the judge is
insane
yeah i don't i mean uh i'm trying to
sort of be as as least hyperbolic as
possible about the judge
but in particular in particular when he
completely fell for this entire um
uh objection from the defense
that zooming in a picture
is in some way equivalent to
algorithmically creating 3d images from
a still from a still image and the judge
was sort of like i don't know what
they're doing yeah
it was it was just humiliating it's just
like what just like he's completely not
understanding what's going on
yep i feel like he should have some sort
of uh education on
on what he's judging about
technology-wise there yes yes and the
burden of proof where just the mere
bogus objection from kyle rittenhouse's
attorney led the judge to say to the
prosecution you're going to have to like
bring in a witness and prove that this
is this stuff it hasn't been altered
like wait a second there's been no
serious allegation that it has it's just
some vague idea that rittenhouse's
attorney had it was all bizarre
completely yeah yeah
what do you think will be the verdict
though
uh realistically yeah i i i think he's
gonna get away without any issue which i
wish was not the case but you know i i
don't think
from how it's going i don't i don't
think he's gonna get
get any sort of punishment yeah here's
my real issue
i've said i think self-defense is
plausible in the homicide charges
particularly with anthony huber i think
it's totally plausible the sick thing is
that this kid is already a product of
the disgusting gun culture of the united
states
and his acquittal
is going to fire up the militia and gun
people
even more he'll be seen as a hero
he'll be invited to sign head shots and
speak at gun conventions and whatnot
when this is actually a tragedy what
took place um that's that's really my
concern here
i agree completely yeah
yeah
so um from the standpoint of third
vaccinations have you gotten yours yet
i'm going very very soon i've got an
appointment actually uh in the in the
next day or so
and i uh i will report my symptoms but
yes i'm getting my third dose very soon
that's great i uh i received mine on
friday and i am happy to report that i
am now magnetic i wasn't after the
second dose but now i am you mean
literally magnetic or you just now have
a magnetic personality
just quite literally magnetic oh there's
a there's a lot of metal on me right now
that might be why my laptop wasn't
working actually
i think that explains why we weren't
able to hear you earlier actually
yeah all right maria and by the way
that's a joke maria we're all kidding
we're all kidding i am kidding yeah
thank you maria appreciate the call
thank you all right there's maria from
columbus ohio
pretty damn close to a perfect phone
call i would say